[Music]
welcome back to part two of catching up
with Jason H everybody we are so excited
it's an off the Record uh and here's the
thing for the last 20 minutes I have no
idea what we talked about so we're going
to try and bring it back part two back
to back well no no well so far we know
Jason chenny if he had a son he would
whoop his ass daughter no would you
would you what do you do would you and
later on like to me there's no
difference if they [__] up I'm spanking
both of them oh really girl too yeah
yeah you too but aren't you like
Nicholas Cage and Conair where you're
like a deadly weapon like I could
imagine if you were to spank somebody
they might fly like you probably don't
have the average spank how do you think
I [__] put on contacts I go like this
I just push my brain
in that's a very very good point got
him D and then and then from that Gio
until she has internal bleeding you kind
of are like homelander dude be SI
spice things up then yeah yeah and and
then from that we talked about how Asian
parents are professional gaslighters and
I go actually I don't think they're
gaslighters I think they're so
delusional that they have selective
memory they Gaslight themselves gasl
their own mind and then uh Jason chenny
found out that we have a very similar
background which proves my point of a
parent of a parent beating your ass and
completely forgetting about it he was
going to get into the juicy details he's
going to go to a dark place but he just
decided to dismiss he was like I have
the same thing I relate and then he
doesn't tell me how he relates no but he
said that but I said
it I said I said I also had a similar
experience because three weeks ago okay
my dad was your side he had the you
Jason had the best childhood ever but
it's like I didn't even [__] I didn't
live with my parents till fifth grade
which is really common in the Asian
culture I was like how the [__] do you
know you wasn't even there [__] half
of it
man I mean not even half of it it's like
I I imagined you outside of the house
having a great time so for your first 5
years where did you live who did you
live oh with my grandparents I love them
it was the best beat you up in the first
5 years it was the best no not not my
grandparents you did have a good child
with your grandparent my no but my dad
would visit oh yeah then he will [__] me
up he'll [__] you up when he's visiting
yeah yeah yeah [__] up so when your
dad would come around when you were
living with your grandparents it was
kind of a he came over just to beat you
up like every every time like I I just
feel I I really think so I really think
this but I know I don't want to speak
like all bad he did his best and I
really appreciate it and that's why
that's why I wait wait why did you say
you could speak back here and most made
eye that way yeah we you made an eye
that way man like almost everybody's
talk bad about father here yeah dude
wrong when did you say bad about your
father tell I said almost everybody dude
okay who's who's the other [__] guys
man everybody we all got
Daddy everybody here's got Daddy Issues
I'll tell you one thing tell you one
thing yeah I talk [__] about my dad all
the time yeah but my dad uh he did say
one of the biggest things he regretted
was whooping my ass so he didn't hey he
admit which is crazy yo better than my
dad and my uncle M doesn't remember oh
see I am right see your mom gasl
gaslighted her brain right that's why
he's gender neutral on slapping
kids everybody's together in reality if
he slaps his future daughter he's just
slapping his mom
exactly that's just Revenge bro you see
that we get deep here we go to the Dark
Places go ahead remember and your mom
was like I never did such a thing my mom
was reading through her like 1993
journal or whatever and she's like I'm
so sad for like beating a bark what and
she that's when she called me she's like
hey I'm reading my old journals and it
said like I was really really sad that
night cuz I had to like whoop your ass
was your journals yeah yeah and she was
well I didn't actually didn't know that
she journals until she called me that
one time and then I was like yeah you
whooped my ass like [__] all the time
and she was like what I don't remember
seeing my theory is correct maybe she
was just trying to be like hey someone
wrote in my
journal why would they write that why
would they write in my someone [__]
with my [__] my handwriting
yeah sign my name this is [__]
what's the worst ass beaing your dad
ever gave you what was it like and what
was a bring back the trauma I really
don't think is like I I don't
remember cuz every time is the same
every time so there's two uh weapons one
of them is the machete the feather
duster what feather
duster there's no feather there like
branches but in one oh shom
the broom no no broom like it's like
this it's a [__] Shaolin [__]
stick or something yeah yeah but five in
one right that one and then the thick
one right and my dad likes bamboo one of
uh I don't know if they're bamboo or not
the other one is like a tree thing okay
uh a broom what's the intended purpose
of these things so one of them is a gift
from my uncle and then he gave it to my
dad and then beat your
son [__] your son up with this yeah
happy birthday hey
brother I have something for you we both
hate Jason when they beat your ass is it
like is it like um do you know how many
you're going to get no or is it just no
until screaming and cussing until they
screaming cussing until um they're like
okay now you write why what you did
wrong and do you remember what you did
wrong you had to do sentences too yeah
wow and I remember staying up like to so
until so late to say like oh I did wrong
this what was the thing that you did
wrong but every day I would like you
know act up in class and I'll get kicked
out and stuff and then or like not do
you kind deserved it bro I know I did
deserve it I you learn from the writing
it sounds Justice it's like you went you
[__] up at school and you [__] you
up after yeah but I liked it though
because you go to school you get kicked
kicked out with like your friends and
then um you go to school to get kicked
out with your friends yeah because it's
nice to be outside of school yeah good
point it's necessary but you like to get
[__] up though that's not fun I'd
rather take that I rather oh then be in
school yeah to be in school I remember
that you're a little bit of a huh it was
fine are you familiar with that term a
pain [__] yeah I like the pain [__] I'm
a no that's true cuz it's like what less
than a minute of getting your ass that's
what I'm saying uh but you get to chill
outside of school for 8 hours for8 hours
that's worth the thing no but in Tai one
it's like eight classes so you kind of
have to [__] up every class oh and get
you know and then get kicked out you
have to do a thing but that was the fun
part you know every class I'm like okay
what am I going to do this time what was
your go-to move yeah what type of thing
would you do to get kicked out like I'll
say like like a teacher will say a thing
and then I'll
go they'll ask something like okay who
knows about the E equals MC squ uhhuh
yeah and then I
go you look like a Santa
Claus but it wouldn't work cuz it's a
Taiwan so she's like what are you
talking about exactly SK material dude
you have American
references so they were just
professional roler they were mainly just
mad cuz you were out of
season you look
like p a gun it's flowers it's April get
out teacher did anybody say you look
like that Easter funny and everyone's
like oh [__] this was funny
dude it's just the most random thing I
don't even know if it was funny or not
it Just Disturbed you just wanted to
cause some sort of commotion or like
yeah just a fun thing fun time you feel
like you lashing out for attention cuz
you didn't get any from your father okay
why' you say it like that why why' you
say it like that yeah man it hurt his
feelings when you say that man don't
hurt my friends feel yeah come on I
think it might be true but I was having
a good time though yeah but I didn't
know them but now I been friends with
you yeah because if we get kicked out
together and then we could go to
7-Eleven we go to 7-Eleven stew eggs or
something that was very excitement for
me yeah we could like steal like a a
porn magazine jerk off get oh
yeah with the boys hey is Taiwanese porn
good why you leave like that dude don't
bite your lip when you ask you is
Taiwanese is Taiwanese porn
good um I think we just watch uh
okay yeah Japanese is like the Chinese
Hollywood of porn I
meanwood Chinese Hollywood Taiwanese
Japanese Chinese Hollywood culture is
represented in that state I feel like
you know how American Hollywood is the
entertainment capital of a the world I
feel like the Japanese porn industry is
the porn industry of Asia for a long
time so they
exported expor it ex because I don't see
any good porno coming from other
countries until recently but I I always
wonder this why did they like uh what is
that the square thing pixelate pixelate
I I always wonder that like they
censored it's illegal oh today's video
is brought to you by Factor all right I
know what you guys are thinking I don't
do readymade meals cuz I'm a Bouie ass
[__] well let me tell you something
about factor I know if you're vegan you
probably like they don't have any good
options well yes they do they got
chicken bar Salo right here and if you
look inside it's pretty nice we got a
lot of condensation here but trust me
y'all there's green beans there's
mushroom there's a lot of yumminess I
had like nine of these
meals I was supposed to share it with
Bart but what I ended up doing was
taking it all for myself that's how
delicious it was also I know you guys be
binge watching YouTube espe esecially JK
news and then you go oh where has the
time gone I've been watching for 5 hours
I'm so hungry I go into my fridge oh no
what is that frozen fish that's going to
take me 25 minutes to
make and that's why for all of you
people out there who have hungry
emergencies these delicious healthy meal
preps are for you because it only takes
2 minutes to warm this baby up and
satisfy your hangry
stomach another thing is it comes
straight delivered to your door you
don't got to go to the grocery store so
you can spend more time watching JK news
you could do whatever you want you could
go ask some more emails you could work
from home you could do a lot of
different things imagine all the time
you save not washing dishes not frying a
pan not freaking chopping up vegetables
it just come straight over to your door
2 minutes you eat and you get right back
to the hustle so you could make a
Million Dollar
Baby so if you want to go make a million
dollars cuz you save time and save all
kinds of stress go ahead and grab
yourself a factor hold on the sea the
seashell's telling me where to get it
okay we're going to go to factor
meals.com
slofe 50 and use the code off the Record
50 to get 50 50% off that's code off
thec 5 at factor meals.com sloff thc50
to get 50% off ooh that's a deal that's
half off now back to our video hopefully
you guys are eating Factor meals while
you're watching JK du it's a it's a old
law it's illegal but it's crazy to have
like the tits and the and what they're
doing but it's no penetration
penetration on camera is illegal
and private you can't show the private
parts naked but you still type in
uncensored yep oh you got to
specifically look for uncensored
Japanese
porn yeah do you think that law has
helped Japan in any way in the intended
use well originally it's not a law it's
because during the technological
Revolution Japanese kids were being born
with pixelated private parts but I was
born in America so I don't have that so
you don't have pictur yeah that's why
Nintendo was invented in Japan cuz
everything's eight bit
Y how do you feel about that I I I got
it so speak on your relationship with
your father huh I got it cuz sometimes I
don't get a thing and I guess that but
you get you get what I got it you look
like a Santa Claus you look like a Santa
Claus a different you know thing yeah
like a just like a random goof cuz
that's pretty hurtful nobody wants to
like Santa Claus hey how did you though
how did you how did you become rekindle
the the the bad Flames uh how did you
rekindle Flames with your
father um when you how did you become
friends sound romantic yeah how' you
hook up again with your dad how' you
guys hook up again how you guys fix when
did you guys start [__] again yeah
how' you guys fix fix the dull
relationship yeah rekindle the FL how'
you add some spice to your your love
life with your
dad how did you bring it back up again
you know I I took him to dinner and um
yeah dates are good dude and ask him if
he was a
virgin ask him if he's seeing
anybody dad are you a virgin what the
[__] you went to [__] like Denny's in
Taiwan and he's like yeah you guys are
like so uh my son is
[__] I should have beat him more
actually he's like that's why they he
beat your ass or he's like I beat him
too hard I know I know he just wants to
foret he was trying to beat the [__]
out of me my whole life do you ever like
crack jokes with your
dad yeah but you know but this is the
thing I really feel like recently I've
been talking about this with my M dad
but um but I think he might have bolar
thing sometimes he's like the best
funnest but everybody know like oh what
he's like a taking time bomb like oh
when is he going to be
crazy like my dad's like that like what
do you mean crazy like go on a St a rage
just out ofwhere yell and yell and yeah
wow you think it's stress does your dad
have a stressful yeah yeah but I mean
every is it a is it a mental disease if
everyone has it nah is it a cuz I feel
like nah like anxiety everyone has it no
either we just are all friends because
we just have similar upbringings yeah or
all of our dads are like they're not
even the same culture but they're very
similar yeah I mean is it really a
disease if we all got Co nope nope jeez
that's a good point it's not a disease
time it's the cold yeah yep hey remember
um Co yeah yep it was kind of it was
kind of stupid can you start your next
stand up with that yeah hey you guys uh
you guys remember Co you guys remember
and then don't
continue my
fathering you look like a Santa
Claus that the Santa Claus one isn't a
good one I apologize it's really good
hey asking your dad if he's a virgin
though that's funny so you guys remember
Co I asked my dad if he's a virgin your
dad might if you ask your dad I when I
picture your dad from all the stories
you tell about him if you were to ask
him at dinner if he was a virgin I would
imagine him being like across the dinner
table for me just standing up and
SL and then just sitting back down and
just being like and he would go could a
virgin slap like that
could a virgin does dad like jokes or no
he's like kind of yeah he likes jokes oh
he does jok until he blows up but
sometimes he doesn't like jokes right
yeah sometimes he doesn't like jokes
don't know which day it is like
everybody yeah I guess like everybody
but um so everybody's bipolar yeah
everybody's a little bit bipolar but his
just a little bit extreme though his is
very extreme like what kind of extreme
like giv me an
example I don't know but I think maybe
the switch is really quick like
sometimes you'll say a thing and then
he'll be like what do you mean that
thing and like a Joe peshy on a good
Fellers you know that what you mean you
think funny what do you mean by funny
huh you mean like haha funny like that
yeah yeah yeah like I was just joking
yeah joking and then he'll go on a and
then the mood will be bad for like two
days wow but he knows your whole life is
like joking right yeah but he he but his
is not good point so he's laughing cuz
it's a funny joke and he
go what the [__] you mean by that man
that's how he acts really no no no no
but not not not that extreme oh but uh
uh yeah if I would say a thing he would
just immediately go like what do you
mean that thing and then he'll go um
yeah to' be in a bad mood yeah bad mood
did you did you get in a fist fight with
him no I never I never you never fought
back never fought back wow but I think
it's a mental thing you know like he's
so powerful yeah he's so powerful and
then it's the respect of a father to to
a father and then I was did you [__] up
your dad my brother did I I I thought he
was so cool I thought that was a I
thought that was a thing you have to do
to become a man oh that eventually you
have to fight back cuz I knew a lot of
people who fought their dads so I
thought that was like okay that's when
you know that like you when you can
finally fight that means you're actually
now you know what I did I remember the
day that when he stopped [__] me up
is I think I was in um 11 or no 12 a
senior I was a senior and then he still
threatens me to be like I'll kill you
yeah and then he will be like I'm going
to come up there yeah you know and then
he came up one time and I start punching
myself in the
face I start and I was punching really
hard like both sides he goes [__]
preemptive strike on myself [__] maybe
like 15 20
times yeah because he CU I don't want
him to hit me and then I just hit my
myself and then go like well if you hit
me I'm going to hit myself I could hit
myself harder than you can hit me wow
that's a diss that's a burn and then
what he he we just went back downstairs
no he still said a thing he's like keep
going 20
more like [__] but uh I don't know
[__] crazy that is a big curve ball
though you storm upstairs and your son's
just whooping on himself like that is
Prett all right you go back downstairs
did you watch before I I went cuz I I I
don't want to feel I still respect him
so I I left so he was like man he's like
I bet he was proud of you though he's
like I thought you were a [__] but
today a little tear down his eyes he's
or maybe he was extremely disappointed
in himself him maybe the dad yeah for
either not knocking the [__] out of
him or being like dude I'm right here
man this I'm just talking to him about
you you weren you're it's not meant for
your cover your ears cover your it's not
for you that's pretty crazy I call him a
[__] or something and you only had to
do that one time yeah yeah I think after
that time he just stopped threaten me
yeah so if you're out there and your
parents be in your ass um if you beat
try the strategy but you have to know
that you could beat your own ass more
than they could beat your ass like you
have like blood going down your face and
you're just like smiling like a [__]
lunatic no I was like pretty I was like
you [__] think you could do this yeah
like you
know that bat why did he turn into bll
rat would you suggest that yes Fant Nick
would you suggest that type of solution
for like other kids whose parents abuse
them in other ways I think so maybe
because it's less light cuz now that's
dark maybe you don't have to [__] up if
you hit your father I feel like that's a
crazy thing too what if your father like
touches you though so you you like touch
yourself harder you got to touch it you
touch him you touch him more you touch
wait wait what sorry is this bad I try
not to say it no I'm just explaining to
him cuz he speaks Chinese oh okay I
think you should fight your dad dude I
think that's the only way you get what
he's saying is like what if your dad Mo
then do you Mo yourself
yeah more more
[Laughter]
problem I said touch it like a kid way
too like touchy
touchy oh my God it's so dark
catch that
algorithm don't challenge it is that a
Thing If you said the thing does the the
algorithm say it straight up it's not a
good thing what it's not good for the
algori [__] YouTube huh oh damn more
money more
[Applause]
problem you can do it if I already do it
plus three points for that one you
cannot do it oh God so sad shouldn't
joke about that man I think we should
joke a little bit more about that Santa
Claus how many times do you guys say the
more thing first time I've ever heard no
no no no like about that
subject one more I try not to but
Anthony loves talking about it all the
time try not to because that means the
video is automatically going on patreon
Jo literally promotes t-shirts by
talking about
it we you it's a good idea we should
keep talking about it why don't we just
end the
[Music]
video